well you know AI fall into the same
group there you also have to do is say
welcome to the weekly poll and then name
everyone off if this goes poorly you're
gonna have to fix it like you're gonna
have to do it after me so in post okay
should I try to sound like you yeah
that'd make it more funny all right
ready
you can't be insulted though all right
okay that's Benny mode welcome everybody
to the weekly pool I am you're not host
but currently right now your host Sammy
from the channel Sammy breathes that
over there is south from comic pop that
over there is Rob from comic displayed
over there we have Joel aka
caped Joel aka faul Spinks he's gonna
leave soon apparently our British across
the pond friend we have fowls from it's
super effective and last but not least
we have Benny from comics Torian getting
a heads up I'm gonna pick someone
randomly we're gonna rotate hosting it
now how awkward would it have been if I
had didn't know everybody's names that's
the one that was formally from comic
book cast comic book guys so as usual we
are the weekly pull and we are now we're
gonna talk about comic books
our first up is gonna be talking about
the Super Bowl trailer but by the way
Hugh if you want to bad-mouth any of you
I'm not looking over here I don't have a
camera over here go to channel two if
you guys have any prawns with the topics
yellow Joel anyway today we're gonna
talk about the Super Bowl trailer or
trailers there was quite a few working I
started off I think the funniest thing
in the world was ant-man at Hawk that
was pretty great Hulk and ant-man
fighting over a coke Natalie I love that
this commercial will be the first
official cannon meeting of these two
characters
that's a trivia question down the line
when did these two characters meet it's
the first time you've seen that version
of the MCU Hulk on American soil like
yeah
since the first Avengers movie because
won't seem again until four it's true
well yeah I'm really hoping they meet
the guardians of the galaxy while
they're in space oh I'll be great we're
not gonna see that cameo all Jews Peter
quill is just like flying by you know
what I saw about that commercial with
Hulk and the coke can it was like not
about how great it was it was everybody
saying the can is not proportional to
Hulk matter so he wouldn't be that mad
initially it would just be like oh you
took my my coke what the hell ant-man
fringes ant-man for opening his buddy's
coke that I know that was cute
I feel like like somebody somewhere was
watching that commercial and was just
like well I mean that
well that coats not the same size a lot
of resentment and anger in the world I
just had no other outlet for it they're
like our audiences and all of our
channels that love to correct us on
minor mistakes that we make in the
videos love what we do are here to watch
it like to watch ten percent of people
who watch just to try and correct me oh
yeah oh you just mean in general yes yes
like that makes one thing that kind of
cracks me up like like like I feel like
there are people who will watch my
videos and just be like so when like
he's got to screw up sometimes I go
there it is and it's like there it is
wrong I mean isn't that why we're all
here on this show to correct each other
in a group live to each other's faces
okay but no I personally I loved ant-man
still getting his drinking oh yeah it
looks really expensive
oh yeah like they got Paul Rudd
they definitely didn't even give the
Hulk even like a moment's line didn't
even get Paul they didn't get Paul
Rudd's face they got Paul Rudd's voice
and it might not even have been him I
don't know if I didn't see any official
word on whether now that was him but it
like it was it looked it looked pretty
inexpensive David Kerr Jim Cummings are
one of those great voice mimics doing a
slight Lisp all right impressions it was
a solid video that was fun it was a
little like it was a cute little teaser
because we got well how many months do
we have left until we get to see another
Marvel movie Emma come on yeah awkward
silence as we all think as we all tried
to crunch the numbers and not like jump
here's the real question here's a real
question how many of you guys were able
to answer that question and how many
guys had to figure it out by counting on
your hands well it's February March
you're quiet why is it we simply sitting
in with Sal this is not the way things
are supposed to be right now
seconds was a handful of new footage but
what is important is what wasn't there
and I didn't even think about this until
people mention it they were like Captain
America side has six people Iron Man's
has five Spider Man it's gonna be on
Iron Man's side easily I'm like these
guys are our experts burying the
freaking lead like okay oh you didn't
release the spider-man announcement in
Christmas uh now that we got like we got
a billion people watching this freaking
show or this was one game this is the
time tell every spider-man's in the
movie - okay you didn't do it then
either we'll just wait until the movie
comes out like but now cheese and they
geez dunder Twitter page the official
Marvel Twitter page
it's like oh did you guys want more
question ma yes see what I keep thinking
is because I feel like David I'm not
entirely sure but I feel like they've
said who's spider-man is by this point
haven't they would it be wouldn't it be
great if they said oh it's this guy and
ten doubt just and they but they just
said it was him to throw us all off and
it turned out to be someone totally
different
no I actually would not be a British all
British people seem very pompous yes why
is that
why are you pompous people fast so
British I mean I mean you guys had an
empire that came crashing down after you
got beat by a bunch of farm not a
pitchfork so look I'm not I'm Scottish
we we hate the English when you suspect
us you mean English Scottish so let's
explain haggis we have another in a
while became the Samuel I am excited for
to see this this kid do spider-man like
as a kid I'll I'll be honest I was like
alright the kid looks a little weird
whatever and then I saw that Instagram
photo of him in a Quinjet and I'm like
you look like Peter Parker I'm totally
on board there's there's Google Tom
Holland Quinn Jen you'll get the picture
but it is here's the reason why I like
that he looks a little bit weird and the
reason I didn't like Andrew Garfield as
spider-man because poor Peter Parker
like you don't want like someone that's
overly unattractive interactive what's
away like they just have to be they said
to fade into the background and I think
he does a good job of being able to do
that yeah he could be anybody
and I think that works ten years ago Jay
Baruchel would have made the perfect
Peter Park for ten years yeah he's that
perfect kind of nebbishy nerdy but he
might be a movie star I don't really
know like I just I don't know I guess
when I look at Peter Park in the
comments in just
Peter puck I just kind of feel like
saying oh dear
things might get better for year they're
going amazing for right now and sounds
like no amazing is so bad right now
it's so awesome right to liking it it is
awful oh you're just failing he doesn't
do anything he's just walking places and
telling people what to do yeah he'll
cameo in his own book oh spider-man's
here and let me sell let me let me let
me defeat the lamest of a villains I
will give you that the villains are lame
but if they're all or something
oh no cloak and dagger are inverted mr-
puppets first of all cloak and dagger
strike one second mr. negative strike
two third of all your first arc was all
about the Zodiac game yes it's not that
bad so this art makes it that much worse
because it's just so like boring and
stiff everybody's human faces look
really weird and similar it's just it's
just not but now his girlfriend trying
to kill him with the spider mobile the
spot he's working with shield just like
that ultimate spider-man cartoon Oh
finally that's so terrific I hope
there's more monkey screeches in this
comic because those are always fun
I like Sal's fake excited voice just to
bring back to drinking game Sal rants
take a drink I mean yeah just just to
bring it back to that Avengers trailer -
how cool was it to see Bucky try and
shoot Tony Stark in the head like
literally just like I tried to murder
you judge my sailor breakdown and people
were like you didn't mention the scene
where Bucky trucks oh I've just been
like and their Bucky tries to shoot Tony
Stark and fails but it's a cool scene
moving on
I guess what I was it was a cool scene
are they gonna say that are they gonna
reveal in any way that like Bucky killed
the Starks they imply that super hard in
Winter Soldier so I'm hoping they run
with it in this one cuz it would give
you know Tony Stark Iron Man some
justification as to why he's being a
jerk it's like Steve he killed my
parents
exactly I get that you guys were friends
for like maybe five years my parents
were murdered by the Soviet spy look we
were bros though we built pillow forts
come on alright so I was like what I was
doing the trailer breakdown I was
looking at that and I was looking at the
the first trailer that we got and my
thought was different because it is they
touched it up is different but my
thought is that Bucky whatever it is it
happens to James Rhodes happens because
of buggy like Bucky probably either
either he kills him or just you know
that's definitely where my money's at my
thoughts ease my thought is that that
Steve Rogers is gonna die at the end of
the movie and and now this would be this
would be one hell of a twist what if
Tony Stark was the one to do it because
we know that crossbones is in there and
we know that crossbones because remember
in the comic across bones just shot the
distracting shot yeah he didn't he
didn't kill him
he just distracted him and I think would
be like if they got to a fight whatever
the case may be I think it'd be amazing
of Tony Stark was the one that killed
Rogers and possibly Baron Zemo is going
to be in the movie too boss that's one
thing I've said we haven't see we
haven't heard one iota haven't seen one
iota of him
maybe Zemo is the post-credit maybe that
Zemo turning around his chair and being
like nearby you know be like would
surprise all of us if they just like
died
other than the ones they're carrying in
later movies Wow white looks light yeah
done a three you know yeah you know be
really cool to see in a Captain America
movie the Red Skull
yeah get someone else it's a red mask
could literally be you know Hugo Weaving
played Megatron and all those transport
in two of those transformers movies and
then he chit and then they recast him
after like the second one or whatever
yeah you didn't notice that because we
can easily recast amigos to the two
through the tesseract when he comes back
he's famished let's talk about the next
topic that Jewell picked out over here
versus Fabien newzeas on the Caesar
Caesar I don't know or what what do you
say Sal you say different you say nah
see answer sometime EC ASA
he says so so yeah for those who are
wondering uh Deadpool comes up this week
comes out Friday for me and I think for
most people in North America comes along
and because oh right on and because of
that Rob Liefeld you know he's been
doing the interview circuit people have
been talking to him and he did a piece
for the New York Times where apparently
he went out of his way to [ __ ] on
Deadpool co-creator Fabian Aziza now
this story has evolved since I put it on
the list because apparently Anna Caesar
came out in his own Twitter and what no
no no no I I talked to rob it's all fine
you know it's this guy took news of
balls man and so yeah he said he didn't
do this I find this subject because Rob
Liefeld has a long storied history of
putting his foot in his mouth like when
he left DC Comics and said everyone
there was d-list talent and got into it
with Scott Snyder saying you don't sell
the book Batman guy who has a long
history of fighting with his cable
co-creator as well which makes me
believe this is true as well
probably I'm sure that the Caesar and
knew Caesar or whatever is trying to
like he's like look this is we're
getting some screen time here man we
were interviewed by the Newark freak
times like play ball the movies out
we're gonna get more work it's gonna be
great like you know keep it together man
oh well I was one thing I was thinking
about to you is I was going through and
I was looking at some of the old
Deadpool comics I remembered that you
guys said that Rob Liefeld couldn't draw
a feed and I was I was sitting there
thinking like I was I was checking out
Deadpool's feet and I was like man like
that's like you can't draw no don't say
that to rob liefeld space cuz you liar
back heel fire back Nolan does it draw
feet you don't have a problem with that
so I will say like look it's a lot of
crap and it's inordinate blood you know
like okay like did the dude borrow like
you know some drawings like occasionally
was he informed by the by other art yeah
like but he was self-taught and he
worked out you know in the industry
legitimately and you know like he has a
fine deserves
nobody really deserves to like be
crapped on at a convention you're
sitting at a card table you're
surrounded by you know the the geek
culture and somebody comes up to you and
it sounds like you don't deserve all the
money in like you know notoriety you got
20 years I'll admit that's uncool like
that sucks and that's what I feel every
time I hear about Rob Liefeld the news I
was think about like there was this book
that was made like the early nineties in
late 80s called how to draw comics the
Marvel way it's a horrible one
I had it when I was a kid I wanted to
draw and I wanted to learn how to draw
comics terrible book but it's so funny
because it's like draw the pictures and
then come up with the story like it's
just all but but somebody threw it at
Rob Liefeld at a convention it's on
YouTube you can watch it anytime it's
just like freaking break you sure
somebody threw that book at Rob like
well they were they know like hey could
you sign this and keep it and he's like
again like being not a great artist okay
sure whatever being a not great war
writers sure whatever that's not me for
to say everything suggests him or
subject him the thing that gets me was
the story I heard what I plan to cover
on super suits one of these days the
lawsuit wherein he sued one of the
widows or one productions it sure is bet
even know how to plug your own stuff
I'm learning quick you know when when
Rob Liefeld sued like one of the widows
of one of the creators of Captain
America yeah that was a thing that
happened well yeah he was working on
fighting American I think yes that was
the thing yeah for fighting up come on
in for fighting American come on babe
and some candy the universe provided I
was I was thinking about Deadpool the
movie the other day and being yes bigger
Deadpool I was think about the movie
today and I was thinking about how like
unfortunate it is that dead no matter
what happens if Deadpool is great the
sequel will suck and if it sucks we're
never gonna get a sequel and the reason
I think we're gonna have a Ghostbusters
2 phenomenon where Fox is gonna go we
made this all rated movie and if it does
great and it makes a lot of money Fox is
gonna go yeah but if it wasn't are
imagine how much more money we could
make and then they're gonna sanitize the
crap out of it and he's gonna be Dipple
will be like a pain in the ass like
g-rated joke machine it'll be so quick
like they'll take away all the
cigarettes and sex and you know like
Turtles to like that one like turtles to
just let us do it now like we don't know
what we're doing just exactly they don't
know like they don't know what they're
like I don't care here's like I don't
know however much it was probably 60
million dollars go do whatever but like
if it succeeds they're gonna be like
okay pg-13 Deadpool to next year and I
don't have a good opening weekend at
least oh for sure yeah what's coming out
besides Deadpool this weekend like
there's even really a good rom-com
4-valent see I'm sad no rom-coms I want
to go and cry my eyes out to some girl
not getting the man that she loves with
Deadpool I'm not gonna like
my whole situation is if this movie does
well then we get the sequel that will
probably not do well in terms of critics
but because so many people like the
first movie the same amount of people
will go see the second one then we'll
end up with the third one which is the
reason why should you like feel free zoo
Lander twos coming out that's okay
that's then that's gonna be a problem
the rom-com of this valentine's oh yeah
there was released those kind of movies
on that like how to be single just go
home and i scream and cry single single
I give you I can write a book about it
for the first ones like wasn't last
year's one coming Fifty Shades of Grey I
think it was it was and this year we
have fifty shades of black from deeply
Larry is looking actually really is I
kinda want to say although I fear with
that when they put all the funny jokes
in the trailer is the thing room like
ooh but I wouldn't pay money to go see
it I don't know like I feel like Damon
Wayans movies have been struggling since
like the first scary movie yesterday
happened and it's just been like I liked
white chicks which was really good you
can put that quote on the move be Betty
from comic history it says white like
she was a good comic story with the
queen of this podcast I am just
addressing that this is the gay of this
podcast get it right Benny
next topic move on let's go quickly
quickly okay you know I'll skip the Zack
Snyder one because this one's a little
old now and a little picked over yeah I
know right we don't need to get Scott
Snyder is not changing superman zack
snyder an interview when again answering
more Man of Steel related questions came
out so hey
I didn't change Superman Canon - which
of course because this is the Internet
people were quick to find several panels
and several instances where it's like
well we can point to here here in a year
sir where you actually did if anything
it just sounds weird that he says I
didn't change Superman can it's like
what Canon he's a character who's
existed for 75 years did you not change
the Golden Age Canon did you not change
this new speaking only only way like
that he wouldn't have changed anything
is if he made a movie that was frame for
frame the exact same as a comic wait
unless he's done that he's changed
something
understand like a Man of Steel
completely retconned
the 75 year history is degree said
they've all been resent you no no okay
so here's a funny thing because I've
noticed it like like Zack Snyder's been
on this tour of interviews ever since
like the second trailer yeah I guess
really the first trailer for Justice
League dropped and I feel like this is
more of like panic mode oh no because
like the trailers came out and
everybody's like well now we know what
the movies about and he said well no no
no no wait a minute guys that's not the
trailers like yes it is how long's the
movie two and a half yeah that's it
that's my favorite my favorite Zack
Snyder moment has to be when it was
announced that Aquaman and yo Jason
Momoa was gonna be in like some radio
station where they were filming the
movie was like taking the piss out of
Aqua how lame so Zack Snyder called the
radio station and got on air signal
Aquaman's actually really great because
like he's super strong and he can
breathe underwater and he has a trying
that can cut Superman and I'm like I
mean obviously he can which is the way
Zack Snyder was doing I'm like really
dude you called or Chef John's you know
no no welcome it's cool I got this like
me for itself man like let these look
like they're disk jockeys they're not
movie directors 300 dude shut up but
here's the thing about the movie Aquaman
is not a haka man he's
Coenen in the water I mean like it's
just this is what makes me doubt all of
DC movies just the fact that that
Aquaman was approved because it's not
Aquaman remotely which means to me that
they are ashamed of one of their
character totally so if they're ashamed
of their characters how can I give them
my faith that they're gonna do I think
it's that Aquaman has a track record of
not selling comics even with the new
began revamp even with him being cooler
even with Jeff Jones writing the better
stories no matter what they had never
never gotten away from the 1960s
Aquaman's super friends riding a
seahorse should have done instead of
like calling them himself
like a lunatic she should have called
Geoff Johns and said call your publicist
and have them arranged to be on this
stupid jackasses show and then having
Jeff Johns bring a whole bunch of
Aquaman books that he wrote and say and
tell me how stupid Aquaman is and then
drop the mic and leave like that's what
you do when you want to like prove
somebody wrong you take the facts and
you shove it in their face you don't but
I don't know like out like a motorist
who's angry at road rage just call
someone like a jackass
you made Watchmen and you're calling up
disc jockeys okay next another we're
gonna be listening to chumbawamba's
tub-thumping but really first Aquaman's
lame why did he listen to this one radio
doesn't everybody say crap about Aquaman
like you said like let the work speak
for itself
let the moon come out it's negative
commons like what the fans tell your
negative commenters to go screw
themselves like don't jump in and do it
yourself that's what make me laugh like
he's literally no better than a youtuber
that responds to the negative comments
but don't ich biddies going to try
buh-bye
I don't think it's much of a mouse it's
that they have to make him look
different otherwise no matter what
you're about to see Jason Momoa space on
that 1960s Aquaman bein like way which
is hilariously hilariously they changed
Aquaman up in the comics to make it look
more like the movie and get a warrant
lot which was a total crash and burn
scenario and now they're changing him
back and we're sorry we're sore we're
gonna pretend like that ever happened by
the way I finally saw the Jason Momoa
like Batman V Superman Aquaman action
figure today
oh it's lame but they they like made him
more blonde and they suit is just
nineties Aquaman yes like the stupid
armor thing weird it's like he's caught
they combined like the worst time in
Aquaman's history I know right plus-plus
shitty Conan like you would be like
would you like it for Superman it's like
let's do a lectric blue and red Superman
for this no that's what we're drawing
are intimate like let's add the mullet
to Superman that we need like we the
Superman that's business in the front
party in the back super Superman
yes for this year you were my hair does
not flow downwards it just flows outward
if you rob that's not mine does robbing
thankfully straighten it I'm pretty
white trash so I could probably grow a
mullet if I really tried whoever grows a
mullet and goes the whole year with a
mullet and Sammy you don't count I would
have to hit the gym and become jacked
and then cosplay as dude I would pay
good money to see you just like beefed
up like the right workout and grow my
hair I don't want this to be like a spur
of the moment Sam he's just like
thousand bucks right
I don't know anything about this so
you're gonna have to explain this one a
little cuz I'm sure nobody else does in
our comments Disney is now suing Stanley
media in the world of Heroes for having
mine okay here's the thing
so in like the beginning of the Internet
age like the internet boom Stanley
started his own company where he would
make super teams and do internet stuff
because that was what you did had to be
like a competition act like your
characters show on so far yeah yeah
stuff like that Stanley would eventually
get ousted from this company but the
company would continue to run around
with Stanley's name and so that is why
the world of Heroes channel is like 100
percent vlog cake people now yes Stanley
hits Tenten Stanley is not involved in
Stanley media at all he was ousted from
the company and so Stanley media like a
couple years back now attempted to sue
Marvel Comics for the works of Stanley a
man who would they had ox did it was all
very strange
tossed a corporate stuff I don't know
they they left the door they left the
door open and he wandered out then they
locked it I don't know that is
understandable they changed the locks on
I don't know he was out but yeah so now
this has finally come full circle now
and now Disney is ready to take Stan Lee
media to court for cost incurred during
their original frivolous lawsuit and
everyone is rooting for them to like yes
crush this horrible zombie company in
the ground that is bearing the name of
this man we like this whole thing
literally just comes down to this Stan
Lee company that doesn't have Stan Lee
being greedy then you're trying to find
dominance in like the comic book in Kiki
media scene and failing and now facing
the repercussions that's all there is
there's not much to say ever then
they're kind of stupid like because once
in a while we'd
I mean we do go look through other
channels we see what everyone else is
doing that's how we catch the people
copying our formats and we try to get
them trademarked and said no that's fine
brothers anyway channels and I know Sal
and I have talked about it before world
of heroes
like has nothing to do with Stanley and
all the videos get like 2000 views for a
channel with like yours yeah that's so
weird
the only thing they have it's a pretty
big channel and I loved Stan's rants
those were fun yeah and they pretty much
just have the comic book show which is
like the common it's got like nine
thousand overlays and weird tickers
Jonah it's it's really weird it's like a
combination of like early 2000s news
media worse with tickers and like
graphics and then six people just talk
it's weird it's like a show about six
dominant personalities all talking over
each other on upcoming book I just said
that we looked at it like what's going
on with that and it sounds like no it's
horrible
it's a no good very bad show the
opinions of Sal you know reflect the
opinions of the rest of the week
especially if people like to pay us hold
on I'm gonna fix it I'm gonna put a
little ticker on here that says that
mister just flavor running all of it no
Sal's rants do not reflect our opinions
the views and values expressed by each
individual member of the weekly pool do
not do not necessarily reflect all there
here is better than caste but no just
Sal's opinions on everything is just
south yeah drag you down say yeah
there's really not much to say on this
they just just an it's Stanley media
reaping what they so hopefully this
company won't be able to continue going
around using this guy's name because it
seems like really I mean all they do is
call it worldly heroes and that's it
there look look at the stream Sal I mean
that is the weird part like they using
studying for to load yeah it's got to
catch up to where he Wow
so uh so we ready to move on to the next
piece then made it hashtag comical cast
your window there every week with this
now it will not die it's the ongoing
joke I wish it wasn't so yeah so Ryan
Reynolds today I think in a moment of
really kind of counting your eggs before
they hatch says that now Deadpool is a
thing he wants to help make x-force a
thing now and you didn't put that out
why not I'll tell you why not
you tell party pooper facts now look at
Joel I don't want to look at it I'm sure
it's something horrible I don't wanna
look at so the reason why I don't want
folks to do expose is because I just
want my x-men again well yeah I don't
think that Fox is gonna let it go so
it's like you might as well get cool
x-force molten movie
I'll watch though no we might as well
just wait until they keep doing x-men
and then the x-men franchise dies and
then Marvel's like hey we'll take that
okay thanks we're looking like a 10 year
window here before they're gonna be able
to like kill it for good yeah but with
modern medicine I've got at least a
hundred years in me so I don't mind
fighting cuz I'm not actually looking at
the stream right now but I could only
imagine something horrible I can only
only things that result in emails for
Joel looks like another week of my feeds
exploding Joel says hashtag [ __ ] CBC the
only one that keeps us ship running in
this one that's sure like I feel like I
feel like everybody's off doing their
own thing and Joel's like he's like
trying to steer the ship and he's like
trying to get the water and I'm like nah
didn't in Wally who spa
the wheel that's I am waiting for like
that big email leaked from Fox where
there were especially like one email
that gets sent out with like we have no
idea what we're doing right now just be
like we don't know what we're doing an F
insert race here yeah if they want to do
an email where they admit they don't
know what they're doing they just need
to send that one meme of that dog in a
lab coat mixing chemicals released the
waxman origins wolverine poster again
yeah i'll be interested and i bet this
is gonna happen mark my words if i was
to take out my crystal ball deadpool is
gonna do huge it's already on track to
do really huge
imagine if deadpool does better than Age
of Apocalypse and if so won't that just
mess with their minds I think it might I
think it has every chance I'll do it way
I feel like it will honestly because Age
of Apocalypse like they were Voltron
there's a dollar eight Age of Apocalypse
see my whole thing with Age of
Apocalypse looking at it if what we're
mentioning it is with Days of Future
past they added in that fun element like
it was just there slightly they gave me
a glimmer of hope with the x-men movies
like you know just that scene with
Quicksilver
just having fun with his powers and I
was like wow they if they go with this
and see that people likes this part in
particular we might get a good X no
movie and you know everything is blue
again and everyone's wearing leather
again what the hell
know what we did totally backslide
singer from you know first class which
you know he had nothing to do with where
they're actually wearing the classic
yellow and blue like they're supposed to
then for the next one okay it's the
future so they're all dressed like road
warriors and now for the new one black
combat leather again yeah like why is no
one complaining about Roush if they're
wearing so much leather like it's okay
they got powder for it it's fun to go to
the bathroom they're not gonna complain
about the minute focuses on the mundane
parts and then weirdly you get stuff
like all these new commercials like even
the Super Bowl Spa which we failed to
mention for Age of Apocalypse fits forty
seconds of a lot of a lot of footage
you've seen but they keep throwing
Olivia Munn into our face we're like but
look how good Olivia Munn looks as
Psylocke isn't that perfect and I'm like
yeah but how are you gonna build a movie
around psylocke why you gotta be excited
you got to do what the whole like acting
thing which she's not really that great
at so like well also have to deal with
like the nightmarish continuity of
Selleck remember how like she first
showed up and she was the British twin I
do remember like Betsy Braddock I will
say they are doing a good job of
collecting characters like again x-force
Deadpool L V once I lock that makes
money like that's a show that's movie
like my gel 1:03 huh one through three
what about one through three just one
three three the movies no just give me
one through three give me another good
no brew it - give me another one three
something do you have a cootie catcher
just one or two one yeah I know right
what when Benny's planning stuff
off-camera this is never good what has
he been doing this whole time I don't
know alright so Rob knows this game it's
called red flags
oh yes red you red flag way to do this
on the stream and we're at the end of
our topics I thought
flexo awesome so you have two options of
what date you'd rather go on okay so you
picked you picked this yourself you can
have the girl to blame you can have the
girl that gives you the best sex ever it
can literally get you anywhere let get
you in anywhere get me right in any
party or any party anything my girl from
Seinfeld she can open any door right but
she's afraid of stoplights Oh traveling
difficult or you can go with the girl
that you'll never get sick while you
date them and she's a supermodel but she
keeps talking about someone who looks
just like you
but better situation before because
someone who talks about someone who
looks like you but better okay okay so
which one would you guys pick I'd take
you I took number two yeah she always
has someone who's better look into you
yeah I feel like I'm spotting that guy
like that like that guy we're gonna let
everyone pick which one of these three
these two they would go with and the
winner is gonna be that one on the chat
is saying they'd go with number one the
best sex ever can get you in anywhere
but she's afraid of stoplights it's not
a very bad downside cancer sickness
because here's a way around the
stoplight thing if she can get you in
anywhere you can she can get you in
anywhere then you can get rich easily
because it's very easy to network and
then you just travel everywhere by
helicopter you just have her call ahead
is what happened how did you come up
with these options they're built a
million okay so what this game is it's
called red flags and you have a stack of
cards that are perfect dates their
gender their gender nonspecific so like
if I was thinking for say maybe like
here's a guy they can do all of this you
know I mean but it's all positive things
and then you have a deck of red flags
and basically what you would play is you
take three cards and you would pick the
best date and then you would screw each
other over with the red flag since
nobody else has these decks we have to
do it this way okay but it all targets
one person so like so many would go in
sequence so he was so with Sal and he
would say Sal here's your circumstance
and like there'd be a card for myself a
card for her Fauss a card for Sammy and
then we would each get a red flag cuz
you only you only get one card and one
red flag yeah yeah and so then we would
each get a red flag and then that would
have to pick which one he would want and
then whoever gets like whoever wins
keeps that red flag and then it's
whoever has a total number of red flags
by the time the neck is empty is the
winner but it's dude it's really fun
it's like cards against humanity' I like
it when we all play games together
do I love cards against humanity' but
this game I'm going with well like the
sickness is just minor sicknesses like
that like the cold tourism we never get
sick so I would assume everything then
I'm going to cuz I don't want to die
toothaches to toothaches are really
painful I'd rather not get those anymore
thanks aren't really getting sick I just
well they are an infection in your tooth
so think I have its little opera sing
along if we get up doing a scene
Sidney Lauper singing along I'm hanging
up alright so the chat is voting number
one and you guys have already number two
yes yep alright we override the chat you
just have a big button that says
override see this funny table and I
bought these we're like whatever we run
out of topics of ranting like Vinnie
Vinnie got the which one is you get you
got the superhero I get the superhero on
the draw at the hotel I feel like in
situations like this we have to like
ladies at least ones have to play cards
against humanity' only need a more
interesting give me a number one through
five four whoa I need two numbers one
through five fine
however 13 yeah I guess thousand in
Sammy so five agrees well I just get
ignored fine you'd be that way are we
going down a line or something or like
wool okay all right so girl one or guy
one depending on your preference we're
going gender nonspecific individual one
there you go
it has all the same hobbies as you and
loves the 80s that's awesome no gender
nonspecific person to owns a magic
carpet and is a best selling offer now a
salad give me wonderful I already have
one I want I'll go with the two - okay
so person one is also Fifty Shades of
Grey is literally the only book that
they have read and person two which is
the best-selling author and owns a magic
carpet is also celibate you could make
it work how could they have the same
hobbies if they've only read Fifty
Shades of Grey I'd kind of person humble
too because they've got a [ __ ] magic
carpet I mean solid reasoning mold like
as a magic carpet not enough for me like
oh you could go a little high you could
fall easily that's not good sound they
can show you the world shining
shimmering splendid it's cold up there
no okay let me tell you some man like
like having a magic carpet that's fine
that's cool and it's really interesting
and you could literally just like free
people out or you could let you could
like like bump them as you're riding
around and just like knock them over at
what but that's celibacy thing 2016 you
just you just got to work out a thing
with your partner being like look we
cool here we cool no I mean this is 2016
like like no that's
my sister my sister took that stance
she's like I'm waiting until I get
married I was like man [ __ ] I know he's
like am I the only one that's like if
someone says to me oh wait until get
married I'm like okay well I'm gonna do
stuff my sister I was like look I was
like this is 2016 lives I was like you
gonna have a tough time finding a dude
he's gonna wait until you guys get
married like I mean you can but a little
differently you guys are gonna debate
the winner of this which superhero is
better
Machado decide who the winner is okay we
don't have these conversations anyway
okay so we're gonna divide the teams up
here we're gonna put how do you guys
want to buy this is five of you I got
y'all and fast yeah I got your fast I'll
take that okay well no no okay
then we okay because we haven't had okay
somebody has so you get to be the person
that makes the decision but he also
pokes hole in the two argument okay way
since you guys can't pick your cards
always works simple we're gonna divide
your supergirls based upon the cards you
guys pick then you have to fight for
your superhero to be the winner
okay do is give me two numbers one
through three you can be both the same
number if you want you're gonna pick a
one white card one black card okay what
are the teams
it's you inst you and Sammy and Jay
Robin Robin okay
so Joel give me one number one two three
two Rob give me another one one one
number one one one Sammy to - all right
so Joel and we're out on hold on what
was that
I don't know what no I don't buy your
breathing dragon yes this actually is
very fitting
Faustus Sammy you are the Kardashians
with tiny t-rex arms okay I've already
got the winning argument for the clothes
related no you see you're your hero
could look or your character could
destroy the Kardashians
but the Kardashians as we all know at
the same power of as little low bow
where when their blood splatters million
little clones appear for every drop of
blood splattered but the Kardashians
have their own reality TV show that is
true the Kardashians don't die that
doesn't make more Kardashian but there's
a lot of great dragons out there like
smog well I think you know there's a
dragon from the fourth Harry Potter
movie there's the dragon from from
hearts there's the magic dragon yeah
okay but like but like but like when
Kanye and Kim complete their compass all
like magic in the world will go into
this bait wing to like the compass
babies I'm really struggling can't we
just say it's the dragon and move on me
I get to pick again yep forth not one
three three i 133 okay uh three then I
love how you can't count Rob it's
difficult oh yeah three
okay pal okay three I don't know what we
got - all right
Joel and Rob are Barney with clothes
that are way too tight Oh Sammy are my
boss leeching the opponent's health when
touched oh really oh yeah cause like we
just go up to Barney and touch his body
is being squeezed out of the tiny
children the thing is closed that way
too tight leave you more vulnerable I
know I own a lot of Under Armour but but
then we also got the power of the
sing-along I love you ever had a job
where your boss likes to hum all the
time and you're trying to do your work
and then you sat down the boss is
humming you want to turn around be like
Susan shut the hell up but you can't
look closer to boss no Barney Barney
would win because you were just seeing
his sing-along song until you go crazy
plus pleasure Bart Barney's got all
those people he can tag in you know I
like I like Xavier party with too tight
clothes what kind of power is that born
with tight clothes it is a man in a suit
I mean we're not going with like real
Barney like there's a sentient dinosaur
a bar is real to some people they're
mostly juice box drinkers but still is
or they would make it anyway and bow
suchak Barney explained weird that
Susan's story is really convincing I
gotta say I think I think I'm gonna lean
towards the boss leaching health
one-touch Barney
Barney's a hugger yeah let's see what
goes down yeah
yeah now cap it's tied up right one two
three I'll get one okay ah
Rob uh - I have a picture yet I don't
think oh well all right then um fast
three again again and Sammy I'll go for
one to avoid this situation again okay
so Joel and Rob you are a college a
cappella group that is three stories
tall
a cowboy that used to be a bear yeah
okay so you see cowboy that used to be a
bear
it's actually just an old gay guy dude
now he's not hairy he is shaved and he's
got to do something with that hair and
you can't sing when you've got hair in
your mouth and there was a lot of hair
groups are dangerous enough as they are
I mean look at all the types of music
out there what do they do they sing
without music man that means they're
crazy and never count out crazy plus
they're three stories tall they can just
squish you with their musical style a
climb up their legs and scratch him all
of it so he's like Beast I've seen pitch
perfect well I know for a fact with from
the documentary pitch perfect that only
takes one bad comment and then all the
our cappella singers start arguing
amongst themselves
I know but see here's what we would do
though like we would we would contact
our friendship it's perfect and we would
bring in the Green Bay Packers musical
attack okay here's the thing but they
bust out an acapella version of God Only
Knows you know from from bioshock
infinite i mean technically that was
barbershop yeah but then our cowboy
because as we discussed he's a gay
cowboy brings along a sound system from
a nightclub I'm please bring a fire I'm
out no one can hear this 3-story to a
cappella dance okay three the
three-story tall acapella groups like
steps on the okay but like you never
said they were on each other's backs
like they're just three stories tall
like they still people how how are they
balancing question
well you're worried about the wrong
things worried about why you're losing
based on based on the evidence presented
the Cowboys they went with more of like
a YMCA type cowboy as opposed to a
rootin tootin Six Gun shootin cowboy so
while he used to be a bear and he did
have bear skills he had lacked the bear
equipment like claws like to scale a
large person is a taste for honey
sometimes you tap into your past to make
your future Sal because you just rocked
a fortune cookie for me it's just sighs
before bears I'm sorry Joel one two
three one robbed two numbers one through
four one or two three four two and three
Oh God okay uh fast one z33 else do you
like the ability to lift a coke can with
one hand i saw you pick it
you were holding it up like that and
Sammy Wonder for you I'll do four and
three
I really wish it'll be really
embarrassing if my camera oh geez you're
gonna win this one so is your point a
trick yeah I want to hear the arguments
okay so all right everybody so uh Joel
and Rob are conjoined twins that are
radioactive and made of paper you guys
are literally the Insane Clown Posse
shooting hassle and your left leg is
Jack Bauer your right leg is a cheetah
your left arm is Forrest Gump and your
right arm is Hannibal I think I dreamt
that one night we'll on peyote that
exact thing we're radioactive though so
over time will kill you due to cancer is
here's the thing it's gonna be the icy
PT you could make the argument that they
that like the radioactive conjoined
twins might win in the long run
but in the battle the true battle ICP we
could beat you with one Lyn they still
succeed to lose behind their back they
still succeed but we're paper so we can
slide under doors like kind of a bit
absorbent I don't know I don't know if
anything aside from like lie that can
absorb a this might be held a Joel tied
up right now
yeah I think yeah three thing winner
great yeah we'll call on to this to
forget to the end of the car guys
I said the winners gonna be this
argument all right and one two through
to one through four two of them raba
one and three
okay oh [ __ ] okay that's a heck of a
combo house one two three - all right
and once before - not two of them Sammy
one and two just like you you really do
look like a like a like I don't know
like a radio show jockey from like MTV
raps or something like okay guys so Joel
and Robbie you are ten electric eels
that can see three seconds into the
future and pretty good a preacher spider
bought that guy at one point all right
Sam you are an Olympic gymnast with acid
blood and you can create Holograms of
yourself we win we win Doom Patrol
character is what that I want to hear
the arguments let's hear the battle
watch the Olympics if our body doesn't
win us automatically but we'll okay
because as electric eels who can see
into the future we can get you
discredited from the Olympics for taking
performance-enhancing drugs and take
performance-enhancing drugs we've just
got acid blood that you didn't say it's
okay so we're just calling you for like
discriminating against why are we in the
Olympics in this scenario well yeah why
are there electric eels in the Olympics
countless stadium yeah
listen to you man tell me something we
can't do because of our race that's why
so they've started letting electric eels
the future into the you attacked us here
we go even if you attack us our blood
will get
Ahn's that a lot problem is but it is
even if you hit the alien the alien has
acid blunts oh my god none of you guys
ever took chemistry like our electricity
would like neutralize the acid but it
really you're just like a floppy little
electric eels there's ten of us we could
stack up on top of one another no that's
impossible you're too floppy here's like
the bigger question you are eels how are
you forming a plan three seconds you
forget you're like a goldfish you forget
the future help she got us with the gold
the sticky guys made is that art yields
operate as a hive mind there's no way
that's not one of your powers ten of us
so surely we must have some sort of like
electric eel I don't know sign language
or something well I mean the arms thing
is rough more the smartest fish yeah
alright you know what check what do you
think yeah I'd like to see I think you
see what the Chad thinks cuz yeah is it
gonna be Joel and Rob with 1000 feels
like I see into the future or is it
Faust and Sammy with an Olympic gymnast
with acid blood so you aren't so here's
this alright Faust I got this okay so if
you put us right in front of each other
right like we're in the arena getting
ready to fight you've got the ten
flopping eels on the ground and then
you've got us just standing there we
just have to wait them out it's just a
waiting game we've got to hide my like
we've seen like
because we've seen that you're going to
attack us so leagues because we can see
we're basically midnight or we know what
moves are gonna make before you even
make okay now flown over to us until
your argument and now it's all foul so
Sammy you know to this man we're a bunch
of Zen yells men be like the frog in the
palm we do not wait for the fly you know
we wait for it to come to us because we
have electricity okay I heard Sammy's
closing arguments is they're actually
closing argument from Joel and we are
let your kills
we're electric eels that have the
ability to see into the future we do our
time doing our time into the people
we've been to the mountaintop due to our
time in the future we developed a hive
mind because you know travel the future
you can experiences have woken us up to
there to the greener goings on of time
of time and space itself and so we have
it was initially overwhelming but then
we then I have an argument against that
I would like to refer you to That's So
Raven season 1 episode 16 Wow when when
Raven Symone meets other psychics that
can seems the future and she also has a
grandmother that can see into the future
and she did not develop a hive mind at
any point during the well-known series
that's so
was between us and and Raven is that
like we're going places and she's not so
that stuff she is on the view oh are are
just like a case precedent yeah are the
eels sentient together man eels will
respond to a threat based on simply Eva
nature and like like it's not a power
that we initially had but again our
experiences in the future in the future
character he's become bees III have a
prep I have a lenient towards the the
Olympians just because of the xenomorph
thing cuz eels bite they don't like they
do Electrify but only in a defensive
move yeah
they don't use it aggressively although
you don't draw blood by electrocuting
people so the acid blood doesn't really
help we sacrificed ourselves okay cuz
you'd still lose that yeah no no we
don't ignore that way for us to win is
to sacrifice I gotta give it to the eels
mmm because they are untouchable really
we can literally just pick something up
would the Olympians mind my gut reaction
was if we were going with Rob's line it
would be because those eels are
reincarnated Time Lords anyway
that would be a schnitzel or whatever
the heck was at the end of blood-borne
okay close the sentient hive mind of all
the wheels that have the ability to
manipulate electricity have been
defeated by gymnast who was that villain
in the Savage Dragon cartoon like swarm
or something he was a bunch of leeches
in like a clothes could we do that with
electric eels could we just be a bunch
of electric eels in a cloak so real
quick don't leave after this I'm
actually gonna play that Deadpool in the
down corner there um Tzadik low between
me later on she's trying to film some
stuff right now so I'll be starting it
alone Sal anybody can hang off they want
to chat about it but either way thank
you guys for joining us so the main
weekly pull podcast
I am Benny the comic story and you can
find me on comic story in on the YouTube
channel calming story on or on twitter
comic story and no one else matters
moving on that is Sal from comic pop you
can find him on YouTube at common pop or
on Twitter at Sal says what cut
well Benny's dying that is joel cape
joel from cape joel the channel comic TV
nerd sync Elseworlds exchange I get
around and oddly because TV is a twitter
handle is the DVD grouches long story I
know you know like Joel we should have
like somebody made it come we should
have gone with our hive mind developing
telepathy you can't just add Jesus
Christ where a gymnast of super strength
I can learn anything super fast oh my
god we win explain to the youtube
channel comment to explain that is Faust
from the channel it's super effective
and his beauty is pure handle is what
does it foul so it's like freaking them
vodka music with the beats music rhythm
beats music and that is Sammy the only
one here is intelligent and kept her
marketing and branding accurate santeria
across the board
the thing is Twitter recently did tell
me you can have the app it's super
effective if you want we'll hold it for
you for a few months and and I'm
literally like I will kind of want to do
it but like then I've got to go through
all my videos and change my Twitter link
make me poll match your branding Robin I
did it Sammy smart everyone else is
clueless I was started with a different
name that's the thing as we are please
don't tell me that actually your Twitter
handles not Samy reads know it is okay
yeah I'm over here like champion for and
I just did so somebody just threw out
like somebody threw a link in the chat
that is checked out and apparently
they've confirmed a sequel for the
Deadpool movie and it's gonna have cable
I thought you were gonna friggin say
like somebody just posted a link about
eels in the chat the grass Tyson he
agrees that you'll win neil degrasse
tyson somebody actually like made a
really cool photoshop picture too it's
got a Liam Neeson it's cable the
official podcast is coming to an end I'm
gonna start shifting things over while I
chat with you keep talking you're fine
I'm just did it yeah yeah so I guess
we'll slow - in the podcast we'll catch
you guys later
yes we're still alive though